[Applaus]
[Musik]
es herrscht wieder krieg in europa die
ereignisse überschlagen sich stündlich
und niemand weiß wie weit dieser von zug
in russland auslöse konflikt noch
ausfahrten wird alle blicke sind jetzt
auf das aggressive riesenreich russland
gerichtet wie weit wird sein herrscher
putin gehen wie kann er gestoppt werden
welches schicksal droht der ukraine und
europa nun wie ihr wisst sind wir hier
bei visual politik nicht dafür zuständig
mit aktuellen wasserstandsmeldungen zu
versorgen dafür gibt es genügt
newsportale nein wir möchten euch jede
großen zusammenhänge näher bringen die
euch deswegen tagesaktuelle meldungen
richtig einzuordnen paus zu orientieren
und richtig zu positionieren und genau
das wollen wir mit diesem video
erreichen
denn habt ihr schon mal folgende frage
gestellt warum ist ausland eigentlich so
riesig und warum ist es so aggressiv
denkt darüber nach wir reden hier über
das größte land der welt mit nicht
weniger als neun verschiedenen zeitzonen
wir sprechen auch über ein land in dem
dutzende von verschiedenen kulturen
nebeneinander existieren ja alle wissen
ja zum beispiel dass die
mehrheitsreligion in russland das
orthodoxe christentum ist allerdings
gibt es in russland auch ganze regionen
mit einer buddhistischen oder
muslimischen mehrheit mehr nämlich
verstehen will wie groß land tickt warum
ist eine invasion der ukraine vom zaun
gebrochen hat und auf was die welt sich
nun vorbereiten sollte muss erstmal die
frage beantworten können wie ist es zu
all dem eigentlich gekommen war russland
schon immer so groß und wie wurde es
logos nun wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt
ist die russische geschichte voll große
eroberungsfeldzüge und ja kolonialismus
[Musik]
man könnte sagen dass das heutige
russland aus einem großen kolonialreich
hervorgegangen ist doch während andere
riesige kolonialreich wie das britische
oder das spanische irgendwann
auseinanderbrach und nur noch ein
kleines mutterland übrig blieb ist das
russische kolonialreich im grunde
genommen im vergleich zu diesen kaum
geschrumpft klar das was ursprünglich
die aus dem zarenreich territoriale
hervorgegangen ist somit union war ist
auseinandergefallen die haupt landmasse
und vor allem der dominante teil der
ressourcen blieb jedoch in der hand
moskaus
[Musik]
daher lautet die frage die wir in
unserem heutigen video als erste
beantworten müssen wieso eigentlich was
wäre wenn russland im kern noch immer
ein kolonialreich wäre anders
ausgedrückt inwieweit ist zutiefst
einmarsch in die ukraine nichts anderes
als ein versuch die imperialistische
koloniale tradition fortzuführen und was
bedeutet es eigentlich zu den rest
europas und der welt wird putin den
traum seines ego stalin verwirklichen
können als neuer welt saar seine füße
wechselweise im indischen und
atlantischen ozean baden zu können okay
okay erstmal tief durchatmen ich weiß
dass das alles wie extrem schwerer tobak
klingt für viele unvorstellbar aber wenn
die ereignisse der letzten tage uns
etwas gelehrt haben dann dass die zeit
des unterschätzens des gleitens daran
ist würde irgendwie schon alles gutgehen
endgültig vorbei ist putin hat uns in
eine neue ära gestoßen in einer ära in
der eine ganz andere denkweise von nöten
sein sagt und auf diese denkweise wollen
wir euch heute vorbereiten deswegen seid
gewarnt das heutige video wird von
manchen als kontrovers aufgefasst werden
aber dies ist leider notwendig und es
tut uns von herzen leid denn gerade die
jeweiligen kontext immer gegen die
spaltung eingetreten gegen polarisierung
und für dialog und verständigung an
gewissen punkten angekommen kann diese
einstellung jedoch fatal sein dann wenn
klar ist dass die bestehende
werteordnung unwiederbringlich
zerbrochen ist wenn es keinerlei
zwischenmenschliche abmachungen er gibt
auf die man sich noch verlassen kann
wenn nur noch das recht des stärkeren
gilt also schnallt euch diesmal bittet
besonders gut an es wird jetzt für alle
ungemütlich denn es ist der einzige weg
damit es irgendwann wieder für alle
gemütlich wird eine abkürzung gibt es in
diesem fall leider nicht
[Musik]
als erstes müssen wir uns gegen
propaganda wappnen da wäre zum beispiel
das beliebte ablenkungsmanöver wenn er
die laut haltet den dieb schreit denn es
war ja gerade die sowjetunion welche die
europäischen kolonial reiche am meisten
kritisiert hat sie hat den in
kolonialisierung 's ausschuss bei der
uno ins leben gerufen und es ist das
heutige russland das jedesmal
protestiert wenn die usa eine
militärbasis in einem neuen land
eröffnen dabei hat die geschichte
russlands jedoch einfach zu viele
gemeinsamkeiten mit der eines
kolonialreichs der ehemalige
tschechische präsident václav havels
fasste die geschichte russlands mit
diesen worten zusammen das problem in
russland ist dass es nicht weiß wo es
anfängt und wo es aufhört obwohl es das
größte land der welt ist fühlt es sich
immer noch ein bisschen zu klein und es
fühlt sich von seinen winzigen nachbarn
bedroht was hubble ehemalige
tschechische und slowakische präsident
die frage mit der wir uns heute
beschäftigen lautet also inwieweit war
die sowjetunion ein kolonialreich wie
das spanische französische oder
britische empire gibt es noch russische
kolonien könnte man sagen dass die
ukraine eine russische kolonie ist die
unabhängig werden will heute werden wir
all diese fragen beantworten aber bevor
wir loslegen müssen wir uns noch kurz
bei unseren sponsoren bedanken dafür
dass er etwas geld zu uns locker gemacht
hat damit wir euch so schnell dieses
extra video präsentieren konnten siehe
chart ist ein sicheres vpn dass weder
datenverkehr noch meter oder
verbindungsdaten mit lockt anonymität
und cyber sicherheit sind ein immer
kostbares gut und wir alle sollten so
viel wie möglich dafür tun auch im
jetzigen ukraine krieg hat russland als
ersten schritt eine umfassende cyber
attacke auf die ukraine gestartet und
ich weiß zwar nicht ob dazu mein in den
mittelalten genutzt wurden aber vor
solchen sehr beliebten szenarien kann
euch ein festlicher vpn services
vorschlag bestimmte schützen es bietet
zudem zahlreiche sicherheitsfeatures an
wie zb cleantech dass alle cookies
popups und auch fortgeschrittene
identifizierung und nach was ist mit dem
von denen man oft gar nicht sicher
bloggt und die damit verbundene gefahren
beseitigt natürlich könnt ihr mit dessen
hilfe auf websites und internet
zugreifen die in dem land in dem er
gerade zeit nicht verfügbar sind ohne
zensur und für block in ob daheim oder
im urlaub netflix dass in russland
sicher bald geblockt wird und andere
streaming dienste die ihre innere nur in
den usa anbieten von europa aus nutzen
mit surf kein problem aber nicht nur das
mit nur einem schlag runter könnt ihr
alle eure geräte im vpn registrieren
handys notebooks und sogar ihren smart
tv ist wirklich alle arten von geräten
ab ihr bekommt damit einen lückenlosen
schutz und wenn ihr den rabattcode
politik.de angibt bekommt ihren
vorschlag auch eine art von 83%
obendrein die ersten drei monate gratis
dazu den link zu diesem angebot findet
ihr eine beschreibung unter diesem video
also nichts wie los besorgt euch so auf
schlag und weist damit wir uns
finanziell unter die arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt und hilfe des
paypal spenden links den ich euch
ebenfalls in die beschreibung gepackt
habe wir sind euch für jede
unterstützung dankbar denn damit hätten
wir uns auch in zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere videos zu liefern so und
nun lasst uns schnell wieder zum thema
diese videos zurückkommen und zur
beantwortung unserer fragen welche
weiteren kolonien außer der ukraine hat
russland ins auge gefasst
die ära der entkolonialisierung
was meint wir sind die kanarischen
inseln eine spanische kolonie was sagt
ihr zum beispiel zu folgen der
schlagzeile el país sitzt hinter juni
2009 kanarische inseln und balearen sind
laut newsweek kolonien bis das war
gelten sowohl die kanarischen inseln als
auch die balearen als clown in spaniens
nur die oh ich werde euch alles erklären
aber zuerst müssen wir verstehen was
dekolonisierung ist um euch eine
vorstellung zu geben noch 1945 lebte
mehr als ein drittel der weltbevölkerung
in regionen die von einem mutterland
kolonisiert wurden fast ganz afrika
gehörte damals zum französischen oder
britischen empire indien pakistan und
bangladesch waren die tische kolonien
fast ganz indonesien gehört zu den
niederlanden aber was bedeutet es
eigentlich erst mal für die menschen in
einer kolonie zu leben nun es bedeutet
vor allem dass die bewohner dieser
länder keinerlei einfluss darauf haben
wie und von wem sie regiert werden
[Musik]
man könnte sagen dass sie in einer
diktatur leben und zwar auch in dem fall
dass die regierung des mutterlandes von
dessen einwohner demokratisch gewählt
wurde tja und in der regel lebt es sich
in einer diktatur eher schlecht
zumindest wenn man nicht zu einem zirkel
auserwählter gehört in algerien zb war
der großteil der politischen oder
wirtschaftlichen eliten franzosen und
die einheimischen algeria hatten nur
wenig freude an der zugehörigkeit zum
französischen umkehre und so kam die
sowjetunion 1960 zu ohne und sagte das
muss ein ende haben kolonialreich
gehören der vergangenheit an auf diese
weise wurde der un entkolonialisierung
trust gegründet und ich weiß dass einige
leute denken werden un das klingt nach
einer menge beamter eine menge erklärung
die besagen dass die zutiefst besorgt
sind und nicht vielmehr oder die 1960 er
jahre waren die jahre der
entkolonialisierung in kurzer zeit
wurden fast alle ehemaligen kolonien in
afrika und asien von ihren mutter
ländern unabhängig nach angaben der uno
gibt es heute nur noch 17 gebiete ohne
selbstverwaltung aber selbst diese liste
besteht hauptsächlich aus ordnung wie
gibraltar und das ist ein ort an dem
viele von euch gerne leben würden vor
allem wenn ihr das video gesehen habe
dass wir über den felsen gedreht haben
und nein weder die kanarischen inseln
noch die balearen stehen auf dieser
liste warum weil die bürger der
kanarischen inseln genauso spanier sind
wie die bürger des festlandes sie nehmen
an den wahlen genauso teil wie jemand
aus madrid oder sevilla und sie haben
die gleichen rechte und pflichten aber
ist diese liste wirklich vollständig
denkt darüber nach es war die
sowjetunion die vorschlug einen
dekolonisierung komitee zu begründen
aber was wäre wenn dies soll jetzt auch
selbst ein kolonialreich gewesen wäre
sieht das ganze wasser nur gepredigt
haben wären sie schön den wein weiter
gesoffen haben das ganze also eine
raffinierte vom die selbst veranstaltete
haltet den dieb propaganda kampagne war
was wenn diese kampagne bis heute
andauert weil sie so gut funktioniert
und in zukunft funktionieren wird
aufgepasst
[Musik]
warum ist russland so groß
ich komme auch die eingangs gestellte
frage zurück warum ist russland so groß
wenn euch mal folgende karte anschaut
wer dir merken dass russland noch im
sechzehnten jahrhundert viel kleiner war
etwas dieser zeit eine ganz klare iwan
der schreckliche mit seiner expansion
nach osten es begann die besiedelung
sibiriens welches ja nicht gerade das
paradies auf erden ist man muss schon
einer von der hardt besorgt zu sein um
dort dauerhaft leben zu wollen und so
können in diesen regionen gab es
natürlich bereits stämme und nomadische
völker solcher von der ganz harten sorte
selbstbewusste völker die sich nicht
einfach so unterwerfen lassen tja aber
wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt hat ivan
seinen beinamen nicht aus jux und
dollerei bekommen der wirklich große
kolonisatoren unserer geschichte war
jedoch peter der große er wurde so
genannt weil er es war der das russische
reich zu jener größe auf blies die wir
heute kennen übrigens fand ich es schon
immer faszinierend dass die russen
damals ohne technologie oder ähnlich ist
ganz sibirien kolonisieren konnten aber
das ist ein thema für ein ganz eigenes
video allerdings sprechen wir nicht nur
von sibirien
das russische reich expandierte in viele
weitere gebiete die ebenfalls schon von
anderen bevölkert war in den kaukasus
bis nach polen und auch in die heutige
ukraine die russen gingen dabei
natürlich alles andere als zimperlich
vor und fanden bei ihren eroberungszügen
auch all jene hinterhältigen methoden an
welche die anderen großen imperien der
erfolg eingesetzt hatten wie zb die
teile und herrsche strategie aber auch
das ist genau ein thema für ein eigenes
video also aber nicht vergessen und
schwuppdiwupp schon sind der im jahr
1917 und was passiert in diesem jahr nun
sicherlich kennt ihr alle diesen part
der russischen geschichte genau ist das
jahr russischen revolution
der klassische marxismus sagt dass
nation nicht wichtig sind das
nationalgefühl sei eine erfindung der
branche war sie proletarier aller länder
vereinigt euch jeder kennt diesen satz
keine grenzen wir sind alle gleich unter
dem dach der arbeiterklasse doch was
fanden die kommunisten vor als sie in
russland an die macht kam nun sie
erkannten das ist in russland viele
verschiedene russlands gab zum beispiel
gab es dagegen vorne kalmückien oder
volant ziehen schamanische und
buddhistischen stämme in georgien
sprachen sie eine sehr seltsame sprache
die sogar ihr eigenes schriftsystem
hatte aber keine sorge die bolschewiki
hatten ihre hausaufgaben gemacht zu
diesem zeitpunkt hatte josef stalin
bereits ein sehr interessantes buch mit
dem titel marxismus und die nationale
frage geschrieben
[Musik]
lenoir experte denkt mal darüber nach er
wurde in die orgien geburt das heißt er
stammt aus einem land das von russland
kolonisiert worden war die wir heute
sagen würden hatte stalin anderem
empathie für ethnische minderheiten und
ich weiß genau was er jetzt denkt stalin
reden wir über denselben stalin der
säuberungen des hyper zentralismus des
holodomor keynotes und der gulags ja
genau es ist derselbe das leben nimmt
viele wendungen das ist schon mal etwas
was stalin und putin gemeinsam haben
aber dazu später mehr der punkt ist das
tal in not mit 17 die regionale
autonomie verteidigte dh dass jede
ethnische gruppe innerhalb russlands
ihre eigene sprache sprechen und ihre
eigene regierung haben konnte natürlich
mussten sie alle der gleichen
kommunistischen partei angehören das
heißt auch die klassen beziehungen
anbelangt mussten alle proletarier ihre
nationalen grenzen hinter sich lassen so
entstand die sogenannte kuranyi saß ja
eine politik zur förderung der lokalen
bevölkerung in verwaltungs- position es
wurden sogar die sogenannten nass
probierte geschaffen drähte zur
vertretung ethnischer minderheiten um
euch eine vorstellung davon zu geben
stalin eröffnete selbst schulen in den
ukrainisch unterrichtet wurde
[Musik]
sowas mag heute ganz normal erscheinen
aber es war ein ziemlicher
mentalitätswandel für den durchschnitts
russen war es nicht leicht zu
akzeptieren das die anderen ethnischen
gruppen das recht hatten ihre sprache zu
verwenden und ihre kultur zu pflegen
jahre lang hatten die zahlen versucht
die russische kultur und sprache und die
orthodoxe religion rücksichtslos und mit
eiserner faust in allen von ihnen
eroberten gebieten durchzusetzen das
darlehen war sich jedoch darüber im
klaren dass ein land nicht wieder
aufgebaut werden konnte ohne die
regionen stark zu machen er ging sogar
soweit eine politik der positiven
diskriminierung einzuführen um lokale
sprachen gegenüber dem russischen zu
fördern mit anderen worten stalin konnte
dissidenten ohne mit der wimper zu
zucken in den gulag schicken aber was
die sensibilität gegenüber anderen
völkern betrat wirkte er wie ein
friedensnobelpreisträger tja was ist
also das problem bei dem ganzen nun
mitte der 1930 er jahre begann ist in
der russischen bevölkerung zu brodeln
hier in diesem minderheitenpolitik zu
weit in vielen fällen brachte die
positive diskriminierung
russischsprachige menschen in eine
nachteilige laden in der kommunistischen
partei selbst kam es zu großen debatten
und 1938 hatte stalin keine andere wahl
als russischer sprache in der gesamten
sowjetunion zu verordnen die folge im
laufe der nächsten jahrzehnte das
schwankt die ganze sensibilität für die
verschiedenen nationen die den
sozialistischen kulturellen
schmelztiegel der sowjetunion und
bildeten tatsächlich waren bis 1980
praktisch alle positionen im politbüro
mit russen besetzt ausnahmen bestätigen
die regel aber all dies geschah
innerhalb der sowjetunion schauen wir
uns nun an was draußen vor sich gehen
und glaubt mir wenn das nicht alle
kolonialismus warnlichter hell
aufleuchten lässt dann weiß ich auch
nicht weiter
[Musik]
der warschauer pakt
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg teilten die
usa großbritannien frankreich und die
sowjetunion europa unter sich auf und in
vielen fällen verlief diese teilung
schlicht und einfach willkürlich nach
gutsherren oder eben kolonialherrn art
die sowjets übernahmen einfach ganze
länder die vor dem krieg eigenständig
gewesen waren einfach weil sie die
briten und amerikaner gewähren ließen
auf diese weise schafft die sowjetunion
ein einflussgebiet dass länder wie polen
die ehemalige tschechoslowakei und
ungarn umfasste all diesen völkern
wurden kommunistische aus moskau
gesteuerte marionetten systeme
aufgezwungen und wenn sie sich dagegen
auflehnten weil sie ihre freiheit
wollten kam jedes mal die heißgeliebten
friedenstruppen samt hast dich
zusammengereimt einer legitimationskrise
und wie darf man sich das konkret
vorstellen nur es war ja nicht so dass
die menschen zum beispiel in ungarn
plötzlich beschlossen hätten massenhaft
die kommunistische partei zu wählen zum
beispiel fanden in ungarn 1945
walenstadt kurz nach der befreiung durch
die sowjets die ihre militärische
präsenz beibehielten bei diesen wahlen
erhielt die kommunistische partei knapp
über 17 prozent der stimmen doch die
sowjetischen
besatzer schüchterten die
oppositionspolitiker ein und nach und
nach übernahmen die kommunisten die
macht einen putsch auf beraten ähnlich
lief es zur gleichen zeit auch in der
tschechoslowakei ab natürlich waren
damit unzählige menschliche schicksale
und schwerste verbrechen verbunden viele
demokraten die gegen die nazis gekämpft
hatten oder von diesen eingekerkert
worden waren wurden nun wiederum von den
kommunisten verhaftet gefoltert und
ermordet damals denken in diesen ländern
plötzlich viele politiker an auf
russische art aus den fenstern zu
sprengen so wie zum beispiel jüngst
russische erste während der korona krise
um gut zehn jahre drauf im jahr 1956
fasst die ungarische revolution statt dh
dass viele antikommunistische ungarn
gegen die kommunistische regierung zu
den waffen griffen doch der aufstand
wurde von moskau niedergeschlagen und
ich weiß was er denkt das war eben der
kasse kriegt jeder war hart im nehmen
und geben nun ja und nein heute kann
niemand mehr leugnen dass die usa auch
in vielen ländern brutal interveniert
haben um die bildung kommunistische
regierung zu verhindern und dabei auch
demokratische regierungen zu gunsten von
diktaturen beseitigt haben falls
letztere über schicken ein wenig
verlässlicher vorkommen hier haben beide
großmächte einfach sehr viel direkter
wir dürfen hier jedoch nicht in den
sogenannten worte bauten verfallen den
klassischen rhetorischen
ablenkungsmanöver bei dem eine kritische
frage oder ein kritisches argument mit
einer kritischen gegenfrage erwidert
wird um von einem unwegsamen thema
abzulenken und die kritik an eigenen
standpunkten oder verhaltensweisen zu
ignorieren oder zu relativieren denn wie
bei allem im leben geht es auch hier
kein schwarz und weiß die welt ist
voller graustufen die cia in der ganzen
welt die fäden gezogen um den aufstieg
des kommunismus zu verhindern daran gibt
es gar keinen zweifel
aber es stimmt auch dass frankreich
mitten im kalten krieg in den 1980 er
jahren eine koalitionsregierung aus
sozialisten und kommunisten bekommen hat
und niemand im pentagon hat panzer nach
paris geschickt um das zu verhindern mit
anderen worten spionage und propaganda
sind die eine sache aber eine richtige
invasion ist etwas ganz anderes
und manche werden sich fragen wann hatte
ich sowjetunion ist wirklich ein anderes
land in einem reinen angriffskrieg
überfall und damit kommen wir zum prager
frühling
wir schreiben das jahr 1968 die ganze
geschichte wie die kommunisten in der
tschechoslowakei an die macht kam
verdient ein eigenes video und das
werden wir produziert aber kurz gesagt
nach zwanzig jahren kommunismus in der
tschechoslowakei beschloss die regierung
dieses landes bei den kleinen
kurswechsel vorzunehmen die rede ist vom
sogenannten sozialismus mit menschlichem
antlitz oder die damalige presse es
nannte vom prager frühling der damalige
tschechische regierungschef und
generalsekretär der kommunistischen
partei alexander dubcek wollte des
sozialismus in seinem land reformieren
er schlug zum beispiel vor ein
mehrparteiensystem zu legalisieren und
die redefreiheit zu lassen man könnte
also sagen dass er so etwas wie eine ist
sozialdemokratie anstrebte und wie hat
moskau darauf reagiert nun am 20 august
1968 ein sandte die sowjetunion mit
ihren verbündeten aus dem warschauer
pakt in einer nacht und nebelaktion eine
halbe million soldaten und tausende von
konstant innerhalb weniger stunden war
die gesamte tschechoslowakei unter
absoluter politischer kontrolle es
handelte sich um die größte militär
operation in europa seit 1945 so und
jetzt haltet euch fest juli 2015 lange
nach dem fall des kommunismus behauptete
das russische staatsfernsehen in einer
dokumentation der prager frühling sei
ein putsch versuch durch eine
vereinigung verurteilter ehemaliger
nazis ss-leute und nazi kollaborateure
gewesen ihr plan die nato nach osten zu
erweitern daher konnte die sowjetunion
gar nicht anders als die tschechen und
slowaken glatt zu weisen kommt euch
diese kritik nicht irgendwie sehr sehr
bekannt vor scheinbar griff putin in
caracas frühling schon vor jahren auf um
eine blaupause für seine ukraine pläne
zu entwerfen und so können wir uns ein
wenig daran orientieren wie die dinge in
der ukraine jetzt wohl laufen werden als
auch zwischen 1968 und 1989 waren die
grenzen der gesamten schlüssel wacker
nach westen dicht
tausende von familien wurden für immer
auseinander gerissen und die regierung
des landes befand sich vollständig unter
der kontrolle moskaus nach der
gewaltsamen niederschlagung der reform
sozialisten leiteten die sowjets in der
slowakei eine 20-jährige periode 1 diese
euphemistisch normalisierung nannten
hinter diesem begriff verstanden die
sowjets in ihrer zynischen art und weise
repressive maßnahmen wie erneuerung der
zensur auflösung von unabhängigen
gesellschaftlichen und politischen
organisationen und massive säuberungen
sowohl in der kommunistischen partei als
auch in allen anderen wichtigen stellen
der gesellschaft meine eltern und deren
geschwister zb dürften nicht studieren
auch wenn sie die qualifikation dazu
hatten sie alle flüchteten und
emigrierten nach deutschland erschienen
kritiker wurden auch verfolgt und
inhaftiert auch wenn man nicht mehr zu
so primitiven methoden wie den
politischen schauprozessen mit
todesurteilen griff die während des
tallinn ismus in den 150 jahren in mode
waren denn man hat er gelernt dass eine
gut ausbalancierte subtilere zuckerbrot
und peitsche strategie viel
zielführender ist die sowjets überließen
die genaue umsetzung ihrer repressalien
jetzt mehr ihren lakaien vor ort damit
diese ihre kulturelle sensitivität
einbringen konnten allerdings musste
eines klar sein jede
meinungsverschiedenheit mit dem
politbüro und moskau würde eine neue
invasion bedeuten
[Musik]
mit anderen worten ungarn die slowakei
und sogar polen hat nur dem namen nach
unabhängige regierungen sie durften
wieder freie wahlen abhalten noch
irgendwelche gesetze erlassen die nichts
vom kreml abgesegnet waren hinzu kommt
jedoch noch ein weiterer aspekt die
länder waren alle technologisch und
produktiv weit fortgeschrittene als die
länder der sowjetunion sie wurden daher
die ganze zeit über massiv
wirtschaftlich ausgebeutet schon nach
dem krieg wurden ihre maschinen und
ganze fabriken demontiert und nach
russland verfrachtet obwohl sie ja nicht
an kriegsschuld waren und folglich zu
keinen reparationen verpflichtet auch
danach wurden laufend gewaltige tribut
zahlungen geleistet in form direkter
lieferungen oder einfach dadurch dass
ein unternehmen dieser länder sehr
ungünstige bedingungen aufzuhören unter
denen sie mit der sowjetunion handel
treiben
denn anstatt in den westen zu
exportieren und reich zu werden wussten
diese völker zu spottpreisen und
hungerlöhnen dafür schuften dass die
extrem und produktives probiert union
nicht zusammenbricht daher stellt sich
ganz massiv die frage inwieweit sie
nicht als ehemalige kolonien der
sowjetunion bzw russland betrachtet
werden können eine betrachtungsweise die
vielleicht auch putin vorschwebt aber
dazu später mehr denn wir sprechen die
nicht nur von europa die gleichen
beispiele lassen sich in allen
zentralasiatischen ländern finden von
kasachstan bis zur mongolei
der fall der mongolei ist besonders
auffällig traditionell haben den
mongolen mehr beziehungen zu den
chinesen also den russen der sowjetische
einfluss ging jedoch so weit dass sie
sogar ihre schrift auf kyrillisch
umstellten so und ich weiß was er denkt
was hat das alles denn mit dem heutigen
russland zu tun jeder weiß doch dass
sich die sowjetunion 0 90 aufgelöst hat
seitdem sind alle länder die einst teil
der udssr waren unabhängige nation und
russland ist nur eines davon nun die
große frage lautet nun ob sie es
wirklich sind abgesehen vom konflikt in
der ukraine gibt es viele weitere
beispiele vom krieg in georgien im jahr
2008 bis zur intervention in kasachstan
anfang dieses jahres die sowjetunion war
in ihre endphase nur noch ein mafia
staat die bosse kürten die jeweiligen
lokalmatadoren der kommunistischen
partei nach dem fall des kommunismus
stellten sie sicher dass sie die macht
im lande beziehungsweise jedem einzelnen
länder weiterhin behielt das system in
der sich die leute im hintergrund nicht
sie störten und halt nicht mehr nur
kommunistische politiker sondern
politiker aller löhr die unter mafiosi
üblich ist jedoch eine gewisse revier
abgrenzung und auch eine hierarchie
notwendig damit die ordnung unter ihnen
gewahrt bleibt im rahmen der großen
umsetzungsprozesse der wendezeit war es
die beste lösung erst mal alles klar
aufzuteilen und abzugrenzen dadurch kann
jeder in seinem revier optimal wachsen
und es gibt weniger reibereien ja auch
nach view sie kennen den wertvollen
subsidiarität etwas ähnliches spielte
sich auch in den anderen
postkommunistischen ländern ab und
überall auf die jeweils lokale art und
weise während die mafias der tschechen
und slowaken zum beispiel 1993 in der
lage waren ihre tiere zum zwecke der
gewinnmaximierung grund reibungs
minimierung friedlich auch zu trennen
liegt dieser prozess in jugoslawien
leider sehr blutig aber jeder prozess
kommt irgendwann ein ende und es ist ein
folgeprozess 1
auch in russland und den anderen
ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken war dies der
fall und der folge prozess heißt
konsolidierung und hierarchisierung
punkte nach diesen prozess in russland
zu ende geführt und möchte ihn nun auch
in der ukraine abschließen aber
durchdacht werden wenn wir in den
letzten tagen etwas gelernt haben dann
wohl die tatsache dass man seine reden
und selbst wenn sie noch so abstrus
klingen einfach wort für wort ernst
nehmen muss auch nur ein jota darin als
macho gequatsche oder bildes ab zu tun
kann und wird ab jetzt fatale folgen
haben
in diesem sinne sollte man sich auch
genau anhören was er über stalin sagt
und man sollte auch genau hinsehen wie
er in letzter zeit bei seinen auftritten
wirkt aufgedunsen paranoid und völlig
durchgeknallt was ist aus dem witzigen
charismatischen und unglaublich gebieten
schauspieler putin geworden der es
liebte raffiniert diplomatische
konstruktion zu bauen mit denen er alle
perfekt verführen konnte oder anders
gefragt würdest du einem mann der wie
putin 2022 aussieht einen gebrauchtwagen
abkaufen nein putin der meister der
täuschung ist tot
[Musik]
vielleicht hat ihn ja die permanente
sorge dass er nicht der einzige
giftmörderin russland sein muss doch
letztendlich zermürbt erscheint auf
jeden fall jene phase in der karriere
eines tyrannen erreicht zu haben in der
sie einfach nur noch angst vor kontakt
zum menschen haben oder vom menschen
allgemeinen und das einzige was
gefährlicher ist als verrückter mit
atomwaffen ist ein verrückter mit
atomwaffen der josef stalin vergöttert
ein psychopath der den namen des
massenmörder stalin reinwaschen möchte
und der russland als ein großes
koloniales imperium sieht sein
persönliches kolonialreich dass er
zunächst in vollständiger größe erneuern
und dann weiter ausbauen möchte koste es
was es wolle unter seiner führung
verwandelt sich die russische föderation
mit voller geschwindigkeit so einen
paria staat der farmen und von den
internationalen wirtschafts strömen
isoliert wird mit seinem jüngsten
schachzug hat er beschlossen der
ukrainischen wie der russischen
bevölkerung enormen schaden zuzufügen
die aussichten beider völker auf eine
blühende zukunft schwinden immer mehr
wir kennen dieses verhalten nur zu gut
aus der geschichte zahlreiche diktatoren
mit narzisstischen
persönlichkeitsstörung haben ihr eigenes
volk in den untergang gerissen weil sie
sich von ihm beraten fühlten sei es
durch militärische misserfolge oder wie
in diesem fall die sich immer stärker
manifestieren demokratie bewegungen
beider länder
[Musik]
putin hat jetzt einen heiligen krieg
begonnen und wird diesen zu ende führen
wenn er nicht mit gewalt gestoppt wird
die ukraine ist bereits auf dem altar
des appeasement geopfert worden als
nächstes ist das baltikum dran falls die
nato russland nicht wirklich wirksam dh
militärisch in seine schranken weisen
sollte putin hat angedeutet dass er sich
alles nehmen wird was der westen ihn
ohne adäquate gegenwehr zugesteht alles
sanktionen und maßnahmen nicht
physischen gewaltlosen charakter zählen
nicht dazu diese hat er bereits fest
einkalkuliert verhandlungen sind nun
nicht mehr möglich denn alle
vereinbarungen würde er nur zum schein
eingehen und diese beziehungsweise deren
bruch anschließend ausnutzen um sein
eigentliches ziel noch schneller
erreichen zu können wir müssen aus der
illusion aufwachen das alles mit jedem
verhandelbar alles nur eine frage des
dialogs sei denn die geschichte lehrt
uns etwas anderes und die aktuelle
gegenwart lehrt uns dass sich russland
seit dem hitler-stalin-pakt nicht
grundsätzlich geändert hat und wir
müssen uns jetzt auch sehr schnell auf
die wahrscheinlichkeit einstellen dass
es analog bereits einen geheimen ski
putin takt geben könnte
[Musik]
auf jeden fall wäre der konflikt in der
ukraine damit nur eine weitere episode
eines expansion süchtigen imperiums das
nicht einfach weiter zufall dass einfach
seine grenzen nicht kennt erinnern wir
uns an die worte was habe es das problem
russlands ist dass es nicht weiß wo es
beginnt und wo es endet an diesem auf
einer totalen wahrnehmungsstörung
bewohnen gefühl liegt auch deutschland
sehr lange immer irgendwie zu klein zu
sein immer irgendwie zu kurz gekommen zu
sein immer mehr zu verdienen als einem
die welt zugesteht obwohl man doch
eigentlich selbst mehr seine kultur
allen anderen überlegen sei es brauchte
zwei weltkriege schmerzhafte
amputationen und teilungen bis dieser
minderwertigkeitskomplex wenigstens in
militärischer hinsicht unschädlich
gemacht wurde also was meint ihr welche
therapie müssen wir russland
verschreiben wird ist die gleiche sein
müssen wie im falle deutschlands und
falls ja was wären die ersten schritte
in diese richtung in militärische
diplomatische wirtschaftlicher hinsicht
haut in die tasten und sagt uns eure
meinung ich hoffe trotz aller politisch
unkorrekten kontroversen in diesem video
das ist euch trotzdem gefallen hat was
ja gibt es mit einem like teilt ist mit
freunden und vergesst nicht das abo mit
glöckchen und keines unserer videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich freuen uns auch
jederzeit über eine spende von euch mit
ihr unterhält dieses projekt
weiterzuführen denn paypal link dazu
findet ihr in der beschreibung oder
diesem video machs gut und bis bald
[Musik]